you must have seen some breeds of
household animals having especially
shinier fur or strong immunity to
certain diseases
you must have heard that golden
retrievers are one of the most loyal and
human friendly dogs whereas Samoyeds are
the ones that have one of the best furs
according to surveys even life
expectancy in African countries is
substantially lower than a North
American nations what kind of
characteristics affect these
fluctuations
most of these characteristics come from
the organism's genes or their DNA
structure to be specific
what if there was a way to extract these
desirable qualities from their genes and
give them to other organisms to spread
these characteristics
if a particular animal is at risk of
blood-related diseases removing the gene
that forces this vulnerability will help
remove this problem
similarly the agriculture industry would
be much more profitable if we could
enhance existing crops to reduce their
unnecessary effects
all of this is possible using genetic
engineering so what is genetic
engineering
genetic engineering is the process of
altering a DNA structure by either
adding or removing genes from it to form
a newer Gene framework with desirable
characteristics it can be applied to
both animals and plants since both are
living organisms with their own DNA
structures
the resultant organism is often called a
GMO a genetically modified organism
the production and study of genetically
engineered organisms became possible
after Bob Fraley among others
transformed plant cells with new DNA
fragments in the early 1980s humans have
been modifying creatures through
breeding for a long time
over many years breeders have had
techniques that make for certain animal
features such as corn cows and even dogs
but recent developments in biotechnology
have made it possible for researchers to
directly alter the DNA of animals plants
and microbes
there are usually two variations of
genetic engineering the first variant
has the original DNA structure of an
organism fused with some foreign genes
to introduce newer characteristics or
features in the resultant GMO for
example plant genes are often used with
certain germicidal cells to facilitate
long-term growth
the second type features the removal of
certain genes from a DNA structure to
eliminate certain Behavior or
characteristics that may be unwanted in
the GMO
for example removing a particular gene
or enzyme from a species reduces its
chances of falling prey to cancerous
tumors
with so much investment in digital
Scientology scientists don't have to
create thousands of experiments and
store them physically
experiments on genome structures are
further accelerated and easier to mass
propagate since the Advent of machine
learning and artificial learning
organizations like Google's deep variant
and deep genomics have machine learning
models to facilitate easier drug tests
and Gene sequencing projects another
institution Sophia genetics has made
progress using AI models to prescribe
personalized medications for cancer
patients and other diseases
scientists have also been able to
perform gene cloning which is
essentially the process of creating an
exact duplicate of Base DNA material
this is especially helpful in medical
Fields where gene cloning can accelerate
the rapid testing of vaccines and serums
but where does genetic engineering find
its use in today's world
1. genetic engineering technology is
widely used to modify crop plants
genotypes to increase their productivity
nutritional value protein content
resistance to disease and fertilizer
usage High yielding grain holes and
vegetable crops can be produced using
recombinant DNA technology and tissue
culture techniques two it is possible to
generate large quantities of important
medications vaccines enzymes and
hormones at minimal cost by manipulating
microorganisms and plant-based materials
vaccines created with gene cloning
technology do not possess any
contaminants and are completely safe
three
energy crops were biofuels that produce
large amounts of biomass that may be
turned into fuel oils alcohols diesel or
other petroleum products can now be
bioengineered to grow rapidly these
wastes can then be converted into energy
4. the majority of GMO animals are
created for use in scientific
experiments these animals serve as
models for studying the operation of
certain genes often concerning how the
genes affect health and illness however
some GMO animals like salmon fish are
created for human consumption
however there are a few risks associated
with genetic engineering the likelihood
of unexpected allergy risks from some
GMO Foods increases due to genetic
engineering another worries the
potential for the genetically altered
foreign DNA to spread to non-GMO plants
and animals
apart from food animals that have been
genetically modified may have
unanticipated genetic deficiencies or
diseases
research needs to be thorough and well
moderated before running these
experiments to avoid loss of life or
resources in the long run
so here is a question for you
which animal was the first genetically
modified organism created in 1974. one
Mouse two cat
three frog
give the correct answer in reasoning and
stand a chance to win an Amazon voucher
think about it and leave your answers in
the comments section and we will provide
the answer next week we hope you enjoyed
this video if you did a thumbs up would
be really appreciated here's your
reminder to subscribe to our Channel and
click on the Bell icon for more on the
latest Technologies and Trends thank you
for watching and stay tuned for more
from Simply learn
[Music]
foreign